guten abend professor tross genannter
kleber man muss sich fragen ob diese
deutsche sondersituation bestand haben
kann sind wir nur ein bisschen später
dran als die anderen oder sind wir
wirklich auf einem deutlich besseren
anderen weg wir haben relativ zu unserer
ersten welle ganz früh angefangen mit
einem lock down und uns dabei ganz viel
kredit gewonnen gegen dieses virus
nachdem wir den lockdown gelockert haben
im mai ist die inzidenz gar nicht von
selbst wieder angestiegen und da sieht
man schon dass wir in einen bereich
gekommen sind mit unserem relativ milden
locker und im vergleich zu anderen
ländern dass wir eine spezielle art der
kontrolle erzielt haben vielleicht sind
wir unter einen gewissen schwellenwert
dabei gekommen
und das hat uns sehr viel natürlich
verschnaufpause über den sommer gegeben
und wir sind jetzt schon in einer
ausnahme situation in deutschland wenn
man das mit anderen ländern vergleicht
deswegen garantiert dass das so bleibt
denn im moment laufen die zahlen ja doch
wieder davon so ähnlich wie anfang märz
wird dann auch wieder so eine decke
eingezogen werden können wie damals ist
das garantiert ja es sind schon
schwierige einschätzungen die man da
jetzt im moment treffen muss man weiß
gar nicht wie man mit diesen zahlen
umgehen soll und man fragt sich
eigentlich was man für ein kriterium
anlegen muss eine sache die wir in
deutschland eigentlich gut gemacht haben
ist dass wir überhaupt so ein kriterium
haben also zum beispiel dieses kriterium
von 50 auf 100 1000 pro woche fälle die
toleriert werden bevor man dann
weiterführende maßnahmen macht das haben
längst nicht andere länder
ein anderer faktor in deutschland ist
aber auch dass die bevölkerung ganz
besonders gut aufgeklärt ist und auch
sehr gut mitmacht und mitdenkt bei all
den maßnahmen
mal als beispiel gesagt journalisten aus
anderen europäischen ländern fragen mich
häufig wie das denn ist in deutschland
ob wir denn jetzt glauben dass dieses
virus auch über eurozone übertragen wird
in usa ist das gerade jetzt in den
vergangenen tagen noch mal infrage
gestellt worden und jetzt im prinzip
erstmalig ist es offiziell konstatiert
worden dass dieses virus auch über
eurozone übertragen wird und ich habe
das gefühl dass wir das in deutschland
eigentlich immer gesellschaftlich
geklärt haben
aber in frankreich und in italien wusste
man doch ungefähr so viel wie bei uns
warum laufen dort die zahlen so davon im
augenblick
es sind viele andere dinge die da
eigentlich zum tragen kommen also eine
sache zum beispiel vielleicht eben nicht
solche klaren kriterien
die frage ist natürlich auch wie man das
verstehen muss dass da protestiert wird
eine andere frage die die ich auch im
verdacht habe das beantworten zu können
ist dass man vielleicht in diesen
ländern in wirklichkeit doch nicht so
effizient die neue incidents gesenkt hat
so dass eigentlich dort im hintergrund
immer infektionsgeschehen war dass man
zum teil ein bisschen nicht bemerkt hat
zum teil auch ignoriert hat und in dem
moment der lockerung ging es dann gleich
wieder weiter und dann kommen natürlich
soziale dinge dazu in ländern von
südeuropa haben wir ja einfach andere
familien und haushaltsstrukturen da gibt
es größere haushalte da gibt es aber
auch einfach gesellschaftliche rituale
die dazu führen dass mehr kontakt
entsteht und sicherlich auch ein
aufholen bedürfnis nach den dort viel
strengeren längeren lockdown jetzt haben
wir ein neues phänomen am anfang war das
durchschnittsalter der infizierten bei
uns nie im krankenhaus landeten bei über
60 jahren
inzwischen ist das fast auf die hälfte
gesunken was bedeutet das für die
zukunft
das bedeutet er erstmal das nicht so
viele menschen sterben die zahl der
toten ist ganz ganz niedrig im moment
ja also dieses phänomen ist ein klares
phänomen das man in vielen anderen
ländern auch sieht jetzt über den sommer
haben viele junge leute sich infiziert
und wir sehen auch jetzt bereits wie das
diffundiert in andere altersgruppen wir
sehen jetzt es geht in die schüler
altersgruppen das kommt wahrscheinlich
von der schule öffnung und wir sehen
auch es geht in die älteren
altersgruppen
das bedeutet also dass die sterblichkeit
auch wieder steigen wird das ist sehr
interessant zu sehen es gibt eine neue
untersuchung die über 960 studien
parallel ausgewertet hat und sortiert
hat nach ihrer glaubwürdigkeit wie gut
diese studien gemacht worden sind
am ende sind nur 24 studien übrig
geblieben und datensätze von ländern und
wenn man da ganz genau jetzt schaut
sieht man dass das alter das
durchschnittsalter in der bevölkerung
fast komplett ausreicht um die
unterschiedlichkeit der sterblichkeit in
den einzelnen ländern zu erklären es ist
jetzt ein relativ komplexe studie aber
man kann mal ein beispiel geben wenn man
nach denselben methoden für die
influenza die infektion sterblichkeit
berechnet dann legt man beispielsweise
in den usa bei 0,05 prozent in den usa
saß zwei profis 19
bei 0,8 prozent also 16 mal mehr als bei
der influenza
jetzt ist unsere bevölkerung noch älter
als die der usa und unsere infektion
sterblichkeit geht nach diesen kriterien
also dann an oder sogar über 1 prozent
das heißt wir werden in eine situation
kommen recht bald wo es wieder darum
geht alte menschen und verwundbare
menschen zu schützen
das war einer der ganz grossen fehler so
sieht man das heute in der ersten welle
das damals es ein lockdown für alte
menschen gab und für schwerkranke
menschen die dann einsam sterben dass
man intensivstationen nicht mehr
besuchen durfte dass man altersheime
nicht mehr aussuchen durfte wird sich
das jetzt alles wiederholen oder ist man
schlauer geworden
ja also es ist immer so schwer das
einzuordnen da im nachhinein zu sagen
irgendjemand hätte einen fehler gemacht
das ist natürlich nicht so man wusste
dass einfach damals nicht das war eine
ganz neue erkrankung und man musste eine
allgemein maßnahme nun mal verhängen
heute wissen wir beispielsweise des
patienten im späteren kann
als verlauf typischerweise auf der
intensivstation und dort wo eben auch
die älteren patienten dann sterben dass
die eigentlich noch relativ wenig virus
nur von sich geben und ich sage manchmal
behandelnden ärzten
das entspricht zwar im moment noch nicht
den anerkannten richtlinien aber für
meine auffassung sind patienten auf der
intensivstation gar nicht mehr als
infektiös und da könnte man also was
ändern
ein anderes beispiel ist die
seniorenwohnheime das ist natürlich
grausam wenn man über wochen und monate
seine angehörigen dort nicht besuchen
kann wir hoffen hier sehr auf den effekt
von schnelltests das ganze ist noch
nicht spruchreif so richtig aber alle
arbeiten schon mit vereinten kräften in
deutschland in diese richtung so dass
wir hoffen können das vielleicht am
eingang eines einer solchen einrichtung
das dortige medizinische fachpersonal
mit schnelltests eine sagen wir mal
freie testung für die dauer der
besuchszeit machen kann das ist also
jetzt nicht unbedingt gleich immer eine
medizinische diagnose aber dennoch eine
ganz gute einschätzung dafür ob jemand
für die besuchszeit jetzt als infektiös
zu betrachten ist oder nicht und damit
das alles andere da einiges
einschließlich kontakte wieder erlauben
in einer so wichtigen und trinken
situation richtig wenn wir nach vorne
schauen hat deutschland eine chance
diese zweite welle die ja nun ob es nun
technisch eine zweite welle ist oder ein
starkes wieder ansteigen was auf uns
zukommen könnte besser zu überstehen als
das erste und trotzdem bei niedrigen
zahlen zu bleiben
na ja wir wissen ja jetzt wirklich ganz
viel und wir müssen natürlich uns immer
klar machen so eine welle also dieser
begriff das ist ja überhaupt erst eine
betrachtung im nachhinein
insofern sind wir alle die welle und
können dass alle mit beeinflussen
und das ist glaube ich auch dass ganz
entscheidende wo wir schon in
deutschland ganz viel geschafft haben
dass die bevölkerung so gut bescheid
weiß bei uns dass die bevölkerung auch
die maßnahmen die bisher und
zwischendurch in kraft waren so gut
unterstützt also man liest von
unterstützungs werten von über 90
prozent oder über 85 prozent
das ist schon eine große errungenschaft
und ich glaube dass wir alle zusammen
und damit meine ich jetzt wirklich nicht
nur die politik sondern damit meine ich
jetzt auch wissenschaftler oder auch
jeder in seinem privaten umfeld
mithelfen kann das richtige zu tun und
im alltag in den kleinen entscheidungen
ist alltag sich richtig zu verhalten
also beispielsweise muss ich nächsten
monat jetzt 40 leute für eine
geburtstagsparty einladen auch wenn ich
das darf oder verschiebe ich das doch
lieber wie mache ich das für mich selbst
mit dem maske tragen denn wir wissen
inzwischen dass maske tragen ist
wirklich effizient da gibt es inzwischen
daten die wir im frühjahr nicht hatten
früher war das alles so nicht so richtig
unterstützt und jetzt können wir sagen
das muss man machen und jeder hat in
seinem umfeld natürlich auch personen
die es nicht so ganz einsehen die
vielleicht auch sagen das interessiert
mich nicht oder ich verstehe es nicht
man kann mit denen reden und sollte das
auch tun ich glaube das ist eine der
größten vorsprünge die wir haben in
deutschland bei dieser ganzen
problematik der appell des virologen
danke professor das sehr gerne